I'm just trying to make my city a better
place
hey youtubers is charlie so there's a
new daredevil Netflix teaser for season
two but it's a very different kind of
teaser really just teasing the fact that
Netflix is now almost like the biggest
content provider worldwide i did a video
the other day about how netflix might
end up dropping daredevil season two the
same day that Batman V Superman hits
theaters worldwide and just accounted up
like the big thing they want to hype up
with this teaser not only you know
daredevil but the fact that they're now
in more than a hundred and thirty
countries worldwide so just to put that
into perspective if they were to make
some sort of content like say a new
daredevil series they could drop it and
instantly worldwide everybody could
watch it at the same time it is just
like me posting a youtube video that's
really what gets me excited now Netflix
is talking about doing a couple other
big things to you know like providing
less graphic versions of their shows
which i think is kind of weird but as
silly as that sounds I'm always more
happy if more people are going to watch
a thing it just means more people that
can pile in and talk when I make
daredevil videos like oh my god I can't
believe the punisher is so amazing yeah
obviously the punisher would be a
character that they don't have to tone
down if they were going to do a less
graphic version I can't imagine how they
would deal with the punisher series they
were to try to make that less graphic
but I guess there have been pg-13
Punisher movies so if they can do that
then they could probably do a less hard
our version of Punisher for Netflix
really I think the biggest barrier and
this is a problem for me too is the
language barrier like even if you
subtitle things sometimes there are
certain phrases that just do not
translate into other languages and then
there's always cultural differences do
you know different cultures have their
own jokes that are culture-specific so
you guys actually let me know like if
you've ever seen a Marvel movie in a
foreign language just let me know like
if they're any jokes that just did not
work because they don't translate into
your language sometimes when they're
doing dubs of really really big movies
like Star Wars for example they can make
subtle changes to fix that but it
doesn't always work sometimes it ends up
being pretty hilarious and if you are
someone who really likes to help out
with subtitles there's actually like a
YouTube process if you want to submit
foreign subtitles on videos that i make
you have to go in through the subtitle
menu here but there is something that
lets you add subtitles the only real
requirement is that there have to be
English subtitles first so if you don't
see English subtitles and you want to
help out you can totally submit
subtitles if you really want some laughs
though turn on
youtube auto subtitles sometimes they're
hilarious sometimes they just don't make
sense they're just gibberish but
sometimes they wind up being amazingly
unintentionally funny I guess as much as
language as a barrier to getting some of
these shows out to like different places
around the world really it's China that
a lot of film and TV studios are trying
to work with next I mean I mean they've
been doing it for a long time but
because China's cinema is
state-controlled they only allow I think
it's about 20 foreign films in per year
in that short list of films includes big
blockbusters like Star Wars avengers age
of ultron captain america civil war so
if you're a film studio and you want
your film to make money you know you do
obviously you release it in as many
countries as possible but there's a
billion people in China that's a lot of
people that could buy a lot of movie
tickets so if you can get in into China
it's a big deal which is why sometimes
they make huge edits to the film because
China is really specific about stuff
they allow in the country like ghost
stories is really good example of
something that they hate their
government really does not like
supernatural stories so if you lived in
China and you wanted to see one you
would probably have to pirate it which
is actually another reason why Netflix
and YouTube are so awesome like
daredevil season two when that drops it
drops everywhere instantaneously which
is probably the best tool against piracy
now you might live in a country where
Netflix doesn't exist so we will not
judge you if you have to pirate
daredevil season 2 just to watch it but
that's why i always get really excited
when YouTube rolls out in new countries
now the interesting thing about Netflix
and YouTube they're just two examples
Facebook does it too but they tune their
algorithms for culturally specific
things so if there's a big thing
happening in your country you're more
likely to see that unlike the YouTube
front page then something that's
happening in America but like if you're
subscribe to my channel you know
wherever you live in the world within
like a minute or two of me posting a
video you'll see it in your sub box so
even if you live in a country where the
primary language isn't English like
you'll still see my videos just like you
would see other people's videos it just
is really interesting to see how YouTube
prioritizes things based on country
there's actually a joke that PewDiePie
told a while ago where he said that he
did not make the front page in Italy
because the most popular thing to watch
online in Italy with soccer matches or
football depending on where you live I
don't know if that's true but let me
know in the comments if you live in a
country whose primary language is not
English but but like you watch my videos
about the
flash or air like or anything in general
Game of Thrones just let me know I'm
always curious to see where people are
from in related news something that
always translates well into foreign
languages giant freaking shark there's a
king shark video that I'm going to make
tonight David Ramsey the actor the place
Diggle on arrow said that the next big
arrow crossover on the flash is going to
be a king shark episode he and Lyla are
going to be going after king shark so be
sure to subscribe to get that i'll post
that later tonight giant freaking sharks
always translate well into foreign
languages so while you guys wait for me
to post that you can click your tour all
about death storm coming to the flash
season 2 so much awesome stuff happening
on the flash this year and you can click
here for all my daredevil season 2
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody around the world high five at
the same time worldwide high five I'll
see you guys tied
you